[Music]
in a world full of loud movies starring
loud people play to theater scroll of
loud fans one premise will shock and
horrify the modern audience having to
shut the up ah that's better
a quiet place hey can we get an epic ASL
guy to help me out here
perfect explore the near future of a
quiet place on one hand it's a dystopia
where blind aliens kill anyone who makes
a sound but on the other it's every
dad's paradise where a father of three
children can finally get some peace and
quiet with plenty of time for fishin
farm-to-table meals and a man cave full
of TV's that your kids are not allowed
to enter
hey dude can we like trade lives please
watch the offices John Krasinski he
proved he's more than just a pretty gym
face but a wide range of pretty gym
pieces with support from real-life wife
Emily blonde the most badass female
character that's also barefoot pregnant
and not allowed to speak but it's behind
the camera where JK really shines as he
makes a directing debut that's one part
Ridley Scott one part James Cameron
titanic references and six parts
Tarantino foot shots
[Music]
whoa sorry haven't yelled like that
since Marvin home alone prepare for an
awesome Aboriginal horror movie premise
as long as you don't think too hard
about it where everyone always looks
like they're holding in a fart because a
fart or a burp or sneeze would equal
death where footsteps are too loud but
snapping your fingers is fine and where
this waterfall that should be as noisy
as you want but they don't just live
next to the waterfall I mean come on
don't even get me started on the ending
in military-grade sonic weaponry the
government's already developing it under
the Denver Airport so if you love
survival horror movies and
feature-length ASMR videos strap in
but carefully because the straps can get
like really noisy for a film that
started its life as a potential
Cloverfield sequel but in the capable
hands of Big Tuna became a really solid
one-off film I mean come on we don't
need a sequel unless it's like a super
quiet aliens gameover gameover
starring dunder mifflin Shikari au
spaceship spaceship spaceship literally
turning it to 11 or oak or or Chekov
snail the same aliens as after earth or
they sense sound instead of fear anyone
else see after earth rocket no and
the quiet game this is a good reminder
that monopoly sucks and will get you
killed in the apocalypse as if he ever
needed another reason not to play
Monopoly right
hey thanks for opening out a big ASL guy
I'm just gonna pretend that means you're
welcome disestablishment arianism is a
big word you're not the only one cursed
with knowledge everything starring the
rock who as it be the Froot Loops I just
read these comments out loud because I
like them